(digital beeps)
(dramatic classical piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans
like you.
(digital chimes)
(rhythmic digital music)
- Well, it's left to me to wrap up before
but we're not really wrapping up,
we're wrapping up before a
question and answer session that
Isabelle will start to lead in a second
but I do get to wrap up.
It's kind of, you know,
I'm thinking and saying
what can I do to wrap up
after some of these talks
which are extraordinary, right, and
you know I just was
thinking of a few things.
One of them is
we talk about genetic variation
and how it contributes
and we see that there's this
notion of a normal distribution
and this idea that you
can have very, very rare
extreme abilities due to kind
of common genetic variation.
At the same time
we have very rare syndromes in which
like Williams syndrome and
some of the other things
that we heard about like KE family,
very rare genetic mutations
that instead of being
an additive of thousands of variation
that's coming through the population,
that kind of lightning hits
and that gives us insight.
And so kind of as physicians,
scientists, and as
who are curious about these, you know,
when we see this, both of
those kind of provide us
with extraordinary ability or
potential to get insight so.
I thought that's an important
kind of point to bring out
that the study of rare,
maybe rare genetic mutation
but it may be rare because
of common variation as well
and both are, you know,
kind of provide us with
exceptional insights as
I hope you heard from
the many talks today.
Really a lot of food for thought.
And I'm really looking
forward to your questions.
But first I wanted to
thank all the speakers
number one for sticking to time,
which is very, very hard
when you wanna talk about
your work and stuff.
(audience laughs)
You know, your baby.
Really, everybody stuck to time and gave
an incredibly cogent,
beautiful, beautiful talk so I,
I wanna thank everybody for their talks.
(audience and Daniel applaud)
And now I'm looking forward
to a good bit of beautiful
and very tough questions I'm sure.
- So I have
questions for, a lot of
questions for McGaugh
on the memory effect.
And maybe I'll ask Jamie Ward
to come and discuss with him
answer to those questions.
But I'll start first for
okay.
I have two questions for Karen Berman.
Well I have two questions,
maybe it's better
that you read them.
Oh, okay, okay I'll do it.
Were Williams patients recognized
before genetics started?
- So that's a very good question.
Indeed they were
recognized, but not as such.
I forget the year but decades ago
Williams and Baron whose
name I always mispronounce,
characterized a syndrome
that was typified by
infantile hypercalcemia,
failure to thrive,
and elfin faces.
And in fact when I was in medical school,
and I won't tell you
how long ago that was,
but a long time ago,
that's what we had called it,
was elfin syndrome.
The genetic cause of this
disorder was discovered
in the 90s by my colleague Colleen Morris.
So it's been a very interesting evolution.
Since that time physicians'
sort of index of suspicion,
their ability to pick up if
there was a failure to thrive
or a particular facial
construct in babies,
in small children, has increased.
And there's a much greater recognition now
and of course a great interest
in neurobiology and behavior.
- Related questions.
Very related is, can you
encounter cases where
you cannot check that
these are genetic defect
but it is idiopathic kind of
form of Williams syndrome,
like you can find in autism for example.
That's not my question, eh.
- I'm gonna try to address that.
So Williams syndrome is pretty specific
and does depend at least these days
on the genetic underpinnings.
I will mention, this is a
little bit of a tangent, but
in my slide I didn't emphasize this,
but 96, more than 96%
of people with autism
have almost the exact
same deletion on chromosome seven,
and this is highly unusual
that it's so stereotyped,
and this is because of what I explained,
their flanking regions having
very similar sequences of DNA
and sort of getting mixed up.
However, there are very
rare people who have
smaller deletions in that same
portion of chromosome seven,
and they have only pieces
of the Williams syndrome
clinical phenotype.
For example, people who just
have a couple of genes deleted
called elastin and LEMK1
have the spatial problems
but not the personality problems.
So these very rare folks, and
we've now brought to the NIH
for study five families, five kindreds,
and seven singleton children
who have these small deletions,
and we hope that that will enable us
to sort of dissect the
genes that are involved
in a more specific way.
My point in bringing this
up is that the people
who have these just several genes deleted,
are not picked up because they
have the behavioral phenotype
at all, they're actually picked up
because they have a cardiac problem.
Because one of the gene's
that's hemideleted is elastin,
which forms the walls of our arteries.
So they have a cardiovascular problem
and they're picked up.
And it's only apparent that
they have the visuo-spatial
construct problem when they're tested.
But they'll tell you if you talk to them,
you know, gee I had problems in this area
in school, I wasn't very good in geometry,
and in other things like that.
So, the short answer is no.
I don't think that we pick up people
who have idiopathic Williams syndrome
because it is by definition
a genetic disorder
now that we know about it,
and it is related to the first question.
- So thank you, Karen.
And now, Simon Fisher, I
have a interesting question
for you, an easy one I think.
Hmm?
- [Simon] You can answer it.
- No, (laughs) I wouldn't
believe it to you.
What does a FOXP2
mutation do to a songbird?
- Oh, okay, okay.
That's great, cause I've got a whole,
there's a whole talk
on that which I didn't.
So we don't know,
we can't actually knock out
FOXP2 in songbirds because
there's no, well, we don't
yet have the technology
to knock it out completely
from embryos of songbirds
although that's coming.
But people have been
able to use viruses to
manipulate the levels of FOXP2
protein that the gene makes
in certain parts of the brain.
And people have studied
one particular songbird
which is the zebra finch.
So male, young male zebra finches,
they hear a song sung
by an adult male tutor
and they learn to make a
pretty accurate copy of that.
And they're not the
prettiest songs in the world,
zebra finch songs,
but they have a certain
level of complexity and
different syllable types
and different structures.
And the males sing to the females,
and it's a learned thing.
They have to be exposed to a template
when they're young.
And lots is known about the neurobiology
of how the zebra finch males
are able to learn these songs.
And they have particular
parts of the brain,
particular kind of nuclei in the brain
including one in the
striatum called Area X.
That are important for
this learning process.
And so some researchers in Berlin,
led by Constance Shaff, noticed
that the levels of FOXP2
protein that were being made
in Area X were going up
around the developmental time
when the birds are learning their songs.
So they interfered with
using these viruses
they injected these viruses into Area X of
young
birds learning these songs
and they knocked down the
amount of FOXP2 was being made
and they found that the
songs were then not copied
as accurately as the control
birds who had the gene
knocked down in a different place
or ones that had a kind
of dummy knock down.
And there's lots more work
that's been done on that
but it's interesting to see
that this is something that
this kind of auditory
guided vocal learning,
the need to listen to something and then
and reproduce a copy of
it can be interfered with
in a songbird with FOXP2 knocked down.
- Several questions for James McGaugh,
and I think it would
be more fun to ask also
Jamie Ward to come up soon
(laughs) soon (laughs).
Let first ask, I mean,
they ask so many questions,
I don't know where to start.
Okay.
Okay, maybe the first one.
What are the downsides of being, you know,
such a HSAM.
In short, what, you know,
did evolution ensure we all
have that opportunity?
- What's the downside?
Well.
The one first obvious downside
is illustrated by the very
first subject who came to me.
She contacted me because she is plagued
by her strong, bad memories.
She has awful memories.
As a matter of fact, I
doubt that her experiences
in life are much worse than
those that most of us have.
But she remembers every one of them.
And so she dwells on them.
I think that she contacted
me initially because
she had some kind of an idea
that if she could contact
me that they would go away
or that I would do something.
She kept diaries, she didn't kept diaries
for the reason that most people do.
They keep diaries because
they want to cherish
the wonderful things in their lives.
Her idea was that if she
wrote it down in her diary
that it would go away.
That was the plan on her part.
So that's the downsize.
For other people who have this ability,
I don't see a downsize.
Louisa Un, the professional violinist
has a wonderful life
and she's not plagued,
she's rather pleased that she can call up
these experiences of the past.
Is this being filmed?
You know.
(audience mutters in response)
It is, oh.
(audience laughs)
Let me simply say that
it can sometimes make for
difficult personal relationships.
If you remember and the
spouse or the other does not.
Maybe you've had that happen.
(audience laughs)
- Alrighty.
And, okay, I can see it has
an impact on the audience.
No no, no no, no.
Okay the next question
is really related to
something you have in common.
Because there are many
questions but the fact is,
is it only for calendar or for dates
that they have this kind of memory.
Or do they learn better,
you know, at school or.
- First of all, they don't
learn better at school.
For the most part they're quite average.
And they don't learn
better in a laboratory.
They're quite average in learning
in the laboratory.
But there are disadvantages as I said.
In the laboratory, we've
tried to teach 'em all kinds
of things and they really
don't do any better at it
than you and I do on the average.
- So it's a special form of memory?
- (sighs) It's a special form of memory
but there's a caveat.
In all of the work that we have done,
and it's a very serious caveat,
and that is we identify these people
on the basis of us
telling us days and dates.
That's how we get them.
And we have about 100
people who can do that
out of a U.S. population of 330 million.
We have had as you probably
saw in one of the slides
a large number of people
who claim that they have
this ability but they don't.
Now they don't maybe, maybe they don't
because they don't tag
their memories with dates.
And in order to be in our studies
they have to be able to tag
their memories with dates.
Now we're caught in a trap.
If they can't assess
their memories with dates,
how on earth are we gonna validate them?
You see, that's the problem.
And so there maybe a lot of those people
who failed our test may
have an ability like this
but they don't tag it with dates.
And so that's a big caveat.
And we have tried to figure
out how to deal with that.
I get even today about two people a week.
When this first opened
up I got, on one day,
I got 600 people who claimed
that they had this ability.
But most of them do not live in Irvine.
If they all lived in Irvine
we could solve a lot of problems.
(audience laughs)
But they live all over the world,
and we only bring the superstars to Irvine
because it costs a lot
of money to bring them up
and put them up for a week
while we're studying them.
If we could figure out a
way of assessing people
who claim they have this ability
but don't do dates we could learn more.
- So, thank you.
So, I see that Jamie doesn't
want to comment on this.
Do you have your own
perspective on the same
kind of phenomenon or?
- Not so much, I mean I
think I would agree with you
that it strikes me that
it's the date stamping thing
that's interesting about
them and that's what made me
wonder whether some of
them have synesthesia.
I think Jill Price does, but
whether it's a common trait.
I guess, well, you can't
if I asked you a question,
do you think that they
could tell you what date
it's going to be say on
the third of June 2020?
Could they do that?
Because that's not a memory attest
that's something about the calendar.
You think they could do
that, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah that was kind of my hunch.
So I think a lot of their
ability is around having
the calendar as a kind of a tool.
- Just to mix it up a little bit.
We do have a couple
questions for Isabelle.
And she didn't wanna ask
herself the questions.
And actually a few of them,
actually appeared here so
there's a very common question.
Which is, Chinese is a tonal language
and I guess the question
is, is a general question.
That is, do tonal languages
there's this idea that
music ability and perfect pitch
is increased in tonal languages.
So that's one question, is
that an old wive's tale or myth
or whatever, or,
and then the other part of that is
does amusia interfere with speech
in learning tonal languages?
- Yes, I mean that's typically
the good questions of course
and typically I do address
them but I didn't have
enough time, so for the first question.
It makes so much sense to
check if you can find kids
is if amusia in populations
who speak a tonal language.
And when we say tonal language because
they use pitch as a way to convey meaning.
So it's very important
for them to pick that up.
And it is a little bit more fine grained
than what we use in everyday speech.
In English and in French the
way we manipulate prosody
is much coarse, not fine-grained,
compared to tonal languages.
So to answer the first question,
and the other aspect
it's really leading to
the other question related
to speech or intonation.
So among speakers of a tonal language
you do find the same prevalence of amusia.
So it does not protect, to
acquire a tonal language,
does not protect you from developing
that neurogenetic disorder.
First, and it has been documented
in many different papers.
We did it first but it has been replicated
in different countries and
for different languages.
Of course, if you manipulate pitch
so that it is really, really fine-grained
like in certain tonal languages
where pitch is really subtly changed.
Then they do have a problem.
Especially to identify the tones
but not to produce it.
So again we find a dissociation between
whatever it's related to
awareness, learning, the code and
spontaneously using the code.
Among speakers of tonal languages.
So it is a very interesting avenue.
Now related to speech.
Of course we checked
intonation, and as I said
in English and in French
the way we use intonation
in every day life is rather
a coarse use of pitch
compared to what we do in music.
In music as I mentioned in my talk,
it is really related to a semitone
to one hundred cents,
the two adjacent keys,
that's a meaningful difference.
And we do perceive more than that,
more refined than 100 cents,
but in speech when I'm asking,
when I'm making a claim for example,
my pitch would go down by seven semitones,
and if I'm asking a question
or using a pitch accent,
I'm using twelve semitones.
So it's huge.
And even if you have a poor system
for tracking pitch differences
you will pick those ones.
So that the reason they
don't really have a problem
with their speech, intonation, and prosody
in every day life but
if we do manipulate it
and we have done it course
in the lab by a few semitones
then they do have a deficit.
They do show a deficit.
So it's not specific to music.
It's just music relevant.
- Isabelle stay up here for a sec
cause we have a couple
questions, and we have some time.
So, have you found a correlation,
can you hear me?
Between those with amusia
and difficulty in learning mathematics.
- Okay, I have to be a little
bit more specific here.
I am interested by those core currents now
more than in the past because
it's so similar
to the other learning disorders,
specifically to dyslexia
and to prosopagnosia, the fact that people
don't recognize faces and I'm affected.
So to go back to the questions.
We studied and the form I described here
is related to pitch, to pitch processing.
There are other forms of
amusia related to rhythm.
The reason I am bringing
that up is because
we don't find any associated disorder
to the pitch form of amusia.
But we do see
differences for those who
have a rhythmic problem.
They do have a problem with dyslexia.
They do have a problem with other
kind of learning disorders.
I mean they seem to have it all.
So if we study, I mean
I think that by studying
those cases more we will learn more about
the association between the disorders
than by studying the one I described.
- So Isabelle a couple more questions,
I'll just throw them at you.
What's the frequency of
amusia in Western populations?
I guess there's a question
of how to diagnose it but
so the frequency is a big question.
And then there was one other
that's attached to that,
let me see.
Here why don't you ask
that, why don't you answer
that while I'm looking, yeah.
- I thought I mentioned it
in my first slides, I'm sorry
if it went too fast.
But the prevalence is 1.5.
But of course it's always
depends on how you compute it
and this is true for any kind of disorder.
So for amusia, I mean it can go up to 4%,
and it is fortunately we
all use the same battery
of evaluation or the same tests.
So that we can compare
from one country to another
or from one lab to another.
But if you are strict like we were
and it was a very large based
testing, online testing,
of more than 20,000 subjects,
or participants, volunteers.
We could determine that
only 1.5% was affected,
which is large, of course.
Because we only selected
those who were impaired
by two standard deviation below the mean
for the pitch related tests.
We used two different tests.
So we used converging
evidence and they had to
perform correctly on a third
test of related to rhythm.
The reason we do require that
is that there are attention deficit
there are other kind of deficits
that are not really related to music
but, you know, problems to
perform this kind of testing.
So we eliminate those by
using a control condition
if you like, and by
doing that we found 1.5%.
That's a long explanation
but it's a very good question
because it's important to know
how we measure prevalence.
- Thank you, I think
well, we had a lot of
really interesting questions
I'm just trying to.
Maybe, Adam Ockelford could answer this,
although Isabelle probably could too, so,
so maybe Isabelle will
start and then Adam.
Why do people like music?
What purpose does it serve?
(audience laughs)
And there's an evolutionary
question in there
as well, right?
Yeah, so.
Floor is open.
- Well.
Well this is the typical question, ah?
And we cannot avoid it, so.
I like to know what you
reply to those questions.
I mean I have heard that
question for 30 years.
Ah, what the purpose of music?
We don't know.
And your speculation is as good as mine.
Except that nowadays
there are more and more
scientific studies on that question.
For many years we, I mean, it's just
a philosophical question or it depends on
what you believed and of course
they were the kind of provocation of
Steven Pinker who said, oh,
music is like auditory cheesecake.
Pure pleasure for the ears
but it serves nothing,
I mean it's useless.
So, this provoked a lot of work.
Activity in the labs, and we did too.
But what is really
compelling is that music,
we don't really understand
the relation with pleasure,
but this is a way to preserve the bonding
and the group activity.
Music is one of the best cement to
to form a cohesive group.
I presented my first
slide to be born musical
the fact that children who are
moved in synchrony with an adult
will be more social.
I mean they will be more
cooperative with that adult
than with someone who didn't
synchronize at the same time.
And there are lots of studies like this
that are coming up now every,
I wouldn't say every day,
but really recently.
It's something that now
we take very seriously
in the lab and we try to answer.
There is not much about the other idea
that goes back to Darwin
who said that music is
really like the peacock tail.
Just to seduce the other gender.
For now, as far as I know,
maybe you know better.
- [Daniel] I have an answer.
- Oh, okay.
(audience laughs)
Go head.
- How many of you have a teenager?
It keeps you from killing your teenager.
(audience laughs)
It's the only thing you can talk about
with your teenager sometimes is music.
Anyway that's a, sorry for that,
I just couldn't help it.
(audience laughs)
Late in the afternoon.
It's the only thing I have in
common with my 17-year-old.
- Yeah but that's bonding and social, too.
Ah, ha, no I was talking
about something else.
It's just the fact that, you know,
when you play music it's hard to fake.
And so it's telling the other, the female,
that really your genes are maybe better
than someone who cannot really play music.
(audience laughs)
That the idea, I mean it's not stupid.
But it's hard to prove.
I mean some people have
computed the number
of offsprings of very famous musicians
but you know there is a confound.
There is, okay, come Simon, please.
(man speaking in audience)
Not many, I mean, Tim
Farconer has none. (laughs)
Yeah, well, yeah, we can
go back, but believe me,
they don't have many offsprings.
Do you want to add something?
- Yeah there's interesting work by
Colwyn Trevarthen on
communicative musicality.
Which I think goes back to
the early bonding between
caregiver and babies, it seems that
being in synchrony with
little vocalizations
that infants make very early on
is a critical part of
that bonding process.
And it seems to precede language as well.
So it could be that music
is a vital building block.
Cause the first way we communicate
is not through words but
through emoting through sound.
By mirroring that we can begin to get
a sense of what someone else feels,
the beginnings of empathy maybe.
So it could be both ontogenetically
and maybe phylogenetically,
music was a crucial part on
the journey towards language.
- Stay up here cause I wanna
explore that a little bit.
It's an interesting idea because
when I think of social cognition,
the first kind of disruption
in that seen in autism
is this thing called joint attention
that infants are developing and
so it's almost paradoxical that
kind of these, a lot of
these savant abilities,
or autistic and even
non-verbal autistic children
might have very substantial
musical abilities
and in fact you can begin to teach people
and people with, even acquired aphasias,
can do quite well if you
begin to get them to sing,
you know using their right hemisphere.
So I wonder, you know,
if you could elaborate
that connection a little bit
for the neurologist in me.
- Yeah I've just written a paper on
is there such a thing as musical empathy
as opposed to cognitive empathy
and emotional empathy in everyday life
and I think there is and I think
the autistic children I work with
often have musical empathy,
so we can interrelate
humor, have teasing, have
sadness, have joy,
and yet they can't
empathize in everyday life,
so I think that specifically
in the context of music
there is that bonding
but it doesn't seem to
transfer very easily.
I think that's probably--
- You know it's really
fascinating because they do
a lot of children would love to be hugged
and show kind of some kind of
you know those emotional relationships
but without the norm,
you know, the typical,
that's really, it's
interesting, thank you.
Okay, let's change a little bit,
let's go to Doctor Miller.
In the case of Jack,
what significance may lie
in the yellow and purple as colors
that are simultaneously intensifying
as elements of visual perception.
- Yeah so a great question,
and thought a lot about it
and one of the most amazing
things about the patients
who do this is their
language and their thought
is so disordered and impaired
that they almost never
can tell you about this.
But I think
our sense is that with these
diseases which are anterior,
anterior temporal left, or
anterior inferior frontal left,
that there is either release
of circuitry that is posterior
or actually remodeling
of posterior circuitry.
We're in the process of
analyzing all of our experience
with these patients
since I've been at UCSF,
which is about 18 years, and
I do think there are certain colors
that are thematically
used more and I think
purple and yellow are two such colors.
But I think we need
statistics on this, yeah.
- Another, stay up here.
I tried to organize.
To some success.
In your talk you have
mentioned people with semantic
I think it's
dementia making a mistake
about colors of animals.
Does this imply that language determines
that the thesis that language
determines our information
processing and categories.
- I think yes, I mean.
I think we see really two
sort of degenerative models
for this.
One is when the left side
of the brain degenerates,
we lose lots of knowledge about things,
animals, I think, vegetables, food.
When the right side degenerates we lose
knowledge about people and
faces and the emotions.
So very, very different
sort of presentations.
And you know, I think the
anterior temporal lobe
is a node I think for verbal
and semantic knowledge,
the sort of knowledge that we
start layering on as children.
And I think this is the
nidus of the degeneration and
semantic variant and you do lose
these language-based concepts, absolutely.
- So from that perspective then,
if you lose the word frog
you've lost the concept of frog
in that way, is that, you know, with that?
- I mean in Alzheimer's almost never.
So in Alzheimer's often
the anatomic lesion
for losing the ability
to say the word frog
is posterior temporal parietal.
These patients are very different, so
Alzheimer patient frog, yeah, frog.
So it's on the tip of the tongue.
And it's very late in the
process that they lose
the concept for a frog.
But when the degeneration is
left anterior temporal lobe,
the loss of the concept
of frog, what a frog is.
These are people if you
give them an IQ test,
the thing that they do worse
on is general knowledge.
So they are losing, you
know, knowledge about
what Shakespeare wrote,
what a table is made of,
all of these facts that
are accumulated very early.
- Thank you.
So here's a question for Simon Fisher,
are there people born
with speech disability
but who have normal
other verbal abilities.
I'm assuming reading comprehension
abilities, for example.
- Yes.
There's a lot of different types of speech
and language disorders,
many of them are
have high heritability.
There are some speech problems that are
very predominantly just
about the kind of dysarthric,
so you can have a developmental dysarthria
that means you actually have problems
physically making the
right kind of sounds.
In some cases you can
have a combination of
speech apraxia and dysarthria,
although it's hard to pull those apart.
You can have children who have,
there are many kids that we study who have
language impairments,
expressive receptive kind
of language impairments but
they actually, their speech,
their sequencing abilities are normal.
So there's a range of different
profiles of different kids,
and often it's quite messy.
In the early days of studying,
of looking for genes for
involved in language disorders,
there were some people
who were really focusing
on trying to find a gene
for grammar, for example,
or finding specific
lesions that might just
take out one aspect of language function.
And I think most of that
has proved not to be true.
So it's a kind of gray area between
some kids have relatively
profiles where
certain aspects are more
impaired than others.
Many kids have these
kind of messy profiles
but speech problems can
definitely be disassociated from
linguistic problems as well.
I don't know if that's fully answered the,
I've gone in a few different directions.
- Yeah, thanks.
Let's stay up.
Because you said, you're not
gonna say anything political.
Thank you for this
question, whoever sent this.
What would your diagnose
of the current temper
of POTUS be?
Temporary POTUS somebody said.
Some have said malignant narcissism.
Well, anyway, we'll move on from there.
(audience laughs)
- Actually.
Actually I have to say we have a
a student in my lab who's
a clinical geneticist,
so she's trained as a clinical geneticist.
She studies all these different kids
with different syndromes
like the Williams syndrome,
there's lots and lots of these
different syndromes out there now.
And it's almost like for every gene
there might be a little mini
syndrome associated with it
when you get mutation.
And she was going through some examples
of different types of speech disorders
that we were studying at the time.
And then she came up
with a kind of test case.
This was just before
the American elections.
And she basically described
this whole phenotype
including the kind of mouth phenotype,
things like that for their current POTUS
and the behavioral things
that have been said,
and can anyone say anything
about the diagnosis, so.
(man speaking in audience)
Yes.
- He doesn't have Williams syndrome.
- No, definitely not Williams syndrome.
(audience laughs)
And not speech apraxia.
- Thanks, Simon.
So, there was a question
for Geschwind or anyone.
And so anyone will.
We have little difficulty
discussing human variation
at the individual level,
but at the group level things get dicey.
Do we need to find a better approach
to discussing group level differences.
That's a really great question cause
they often get confused and confounded.
And of course there's an
enormous amount of human
individual variability,
and that's the point.
Is that you can't apply means, averages,
groups, to individuals.
And that's where things kind of get off.
I'll just leave it there.
I mean that's, I think
it's a very good point,
and I think it gets
confounded, those two things.
When somebody is speaking
about individual differences,
they're not speaking about the average,
they're speaking about individuals,
and when you apply an
average to an individual
you're losing a lot, usually wrong.
So,
let's see there are a couple more.
Let's see, I think we have time.
There are a couple more
interesting questions for
for Doctor McGaugh.
Get ready.
Can an HSAM remember where
he/she left his or her keys?
(audience laughs)
- No, as a matter of fact
that's one of their complaints.
They lose their keys and can't find them.
And I tested a lot of them
on their personal details,
and Jill Price has never learned
her license plate number on her car.
And she walks past it every day
when she goes to the garage.
So these kinds of incidental things
are not picked up at all
because that's not what they focus on.
They focus on either their lives
and the events in their lives that
they wanna remember or don't,
or even on imaginary lives.
Some of them make up stories which
they maintain, if I
could just say briefly.
One of our subjects invented a
college basketball team in his head
when he was 13 years old.
And he has kept that, as
a college basketball team,
that in his imagination plays other
real college basketball teams.
And he does this on a regular basis,
and he's done this
since he's 13 years old.
He's now 60 years old.
And from time to time I get a news release
that say how well they did
in the NC two A tournament.
(audience laughs)
And so on.
And he spends an enormous
amount of time doing this.
And you might say, why does he do it?
And one answer is because he can.
That is, he has the ability,
and we have tested him
on his ability to remember
all of the details.
They live different kinds
of lives from people who
don't have the ability.
And if they have had pleasant
experiences in their life
and they dwell on that then
they have one kind of a life.
If they've had unpleasant
experiences that they believe
they should remember that's another one.
And if they have hobbies
that require a lot of
this kind of memory,
then they do very well with them.
Thank you.
- Thanks.
I think we're kind of,
most of the other questions
are kind of very similar, so.
Isabelle had suggested
maybe some of the speakers
wanna ask each other questions,
or there are other questions
that people just wanna ask.
I don't know if that's too far out
of the realm of what we do.
I know we're gonna have a whole
day of that tomorrow, but.
I'll repeat that, yeah.
So Doctor Miller wanted
to ask Karen Berman about
empathy in Williams syndrome.
- So the question is about empathy
and are they more empathic
than other children,
did I get that right?
Okay, so empathy is
a broad concept, it's kind
of one of these things that
we kind of know it when we see it.
But it can also be studied in
the laboratory experimentally
in the behavioral lab.
For example one of the
very good papers was about
an investigator who would sit with a child
with Williams syndrome or other children
and bang his or her knee.
And how many, what level of concern
does the child have for that
and it's quite significant
in comparison to typically
developing children,
or children with various
developmental disorders
like Downs or others.
So it's there and it can
be measured experimentally.
And we sort of do know it when we see it.
If I show up to one of
my children with my cane,
I get way more questions
about it than I would
from anyone else and
expressions of concern.
- Thank you.
This question and answer
reminds me of the time
when I was crossing a border somewhere
and my youngest was about five years old,
and he saw all the guards
asking us, querying us
for minutes, each of the adults.
And he came up and he said,
are you gonna ask me a hard math question.
(audience laughs)
Always get worried about that.
Anyway, I wanna thank
everybody for the questions.
Are there any more remaining questions.
I think we have three minutes and
it's really time for closing remarks.
So I'm gonna introduce
Margaret Schoeninger,
who is the CARTA co-director
to give us some closing remarks.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, Dan.
I just wanted to thank the audience,
those people who've stayed
throughout the whole afternoon.
Thank you very much.
I did wanna particular
thank the symposium chairs.
This was an amazing collection of speakers
and really fascinating talks.
You have already thanked the speakers
but I want to thank them again
for coming here and giving us
really fascinating things to think about.
I would also like to thank our supporters,
our individual supporters
who made this possible,
including the Mathers foundation,
but there are others,
individual supporters,
some of whom really don't
want us to give their names,
so I won't.
But we do want them to know
we very much appreciate it.
And then also the questions
that you all have asked,
we very much, it's been a lot of fun
to think about those things.
I wanna highlight,
though, I wanna point you
in the direction of this isn't the end.
We have many very interesting
symposia coming up.
One is in September of next year.
I mean this next fall.
And that will be cellular
and molecular explorations of
anthropogeny, the origin of humans.
In the winter of 2018, I'm
particularly interested in this one,
is the role of hunting
in the origin of humans.
This will not be just the man the hunter
redux, but we will be thinking
about the role of hunting
and obtaining of a very
high quality protein,
is the way I would look at it.
In the spring of 2018 we're
looking at imagination
and human origins.
I had a conversation with
someone during the break,
and I said, how do you
know what my dog imagines
and what my dog doesn't imagine.
So that's the kind of thing
someone is gonna tell us about.
I think my dog has a great
imagination, actually,
which he's asleep.
In the fall of 2018 we're gonna look at
the impact of tools and technology
on the evolution of the human mind.
And we can think about all
kinds of different technologies.
We talk about tools, and
many of them are stone,
because they actually in
the very early period,
those are the ones that are preserved.
But we don't know exactly
what other tools were there
in the very beginning and
we can begin to see things
that are ephemeral later
and that will not be preserved
in a long term fossil record.
So please keep notice of what we're doing,
and yes, I'm sorry, thank you Rusty.
I wanna talk about the future
Kavli Institute symposia.
Thank you.
In December of 2017, we are
gonna have imaging the brain,
from molecules to circuits and beyond.
So we'll take it from all
levels in the brain and
I hope you realize that
the drawing that you saw
in the very beginning with
the yellows and the purples
is the human brain, but
with gorgeous colors in it.
Very similar to the parrot actually.
When I saw the parrot I
thought of this picture.
Thank you, Jesse, for that picture.
Alright, thank you very much.
And we hope to see you in the future.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat digital music)